continuer l'activité de la librairie
pour vendre son stock
voici ce qui a poussé laurent garin
directeur du pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux de rouvrir les portes de son
établissement une ouverture partielle
puisqu'il propose à ses clients un point
relais un service qui était encore
impossible il ya quelques jours il ya eu
un appui du pardon de la part du
syndicat de la librairie française pour
que ça passe enfin comme un produit de
première nécessité donc on n'y a plus de
ya plus de restrictions en soit sur le
déplacement avec justificatifs pour
venir acheter des livres
je suis venu le récupérer des suites de
bande dessinée pour les enfants qui
lisent beaucoup en ce moment à la maison
fait qu'ils se rendent dans pour les
commandes tout se passe en ligne
l'électeur vérifie que les livres soient
bien disponible et envoient leur demande
par mail
le paiement se fait uniquement par
chèque a décidé de pas avoir plus de 2 3
personnes par créneau par quart d'heure
donc ils prennent date sur un rendez
vous ici et ils nous envoient un mail
avec une liste et nous on leur envoie le
montant de la commande en leur précisant
que le créneau a été validé il ya du gel
hydro alcoolique il ya forcément on sait
un mètre de distance entre la clientèle
et moi mais voilà donc les gens viennent
sur ces créneaux et voilà comment on
fonctionne
j'ai pas mal de bouquins parce que
j'avais j'ai toujours un stock sous la
main et j'en avais pris aussi à la
médiathèque
mais c'était surtout la possibilité de
soutenir va livrer je trouve que c'est
important de soutenir les commerces
locaux et le centre-ville qui est
important dans le cimentier plus de
quarante mille ouvrages sont en stock
parmi les plus plébiscités les livres
jeunesse et les livres de cuisine